And another thing I always thought about
was um how if you know Jesus really did
predestin everything then why did he cry
over Israel?
>> That's what the one I use all the time
to bury him. That's what I did to Matt
Slick. Remember
>> because that's not only about
>> limitment because they tell you that
Christ came to die for the elect and
that the spirit will regenerate the
elect. So when Christ comes he comes for
the elect. So they cannot turn from him
but will turn to him. Right.
>> Right.
But uh according Luke 19:41-44,
Jesus came to Jerusalem and her
inhabitants and now he's weeping
bitterly because they wouldn't turn to
him and be saved, leaving them to be
destroyed, which destroys limited
atonement and unconditional election,
irresistible grace.
>> What do I mean? Let me explain what this
young man is saying. And I'll again,
I've done articles and this is the
argument I used. Let me explain to you
what five points of Calvinist teaches.
Okay, listen guys. This is one of the
passages God used to set me free. God
used to set me free and show me
Calvinism is from the pit of hell. The U
in tulip.
Tulip the acronym means unconditional
action. Meaning God already in eternity.
Listen to this. God already and
eternity. Finally, the cat comes in
has chosen out of his own free will
a group to save
not because he foresaw they would
believe. Listen to what unconditional
election teaches. I'm going to have
camera for a minute.
>> Yeah. According to unconditional
election, as I was taught by Edwin
Palmer and others, God in eternity out
of his own free will chose to create a
people whom he would save not because he
saw that if these people were created,
they would believe. That's unconditional
election. He didn't see anything in them
that would be the basis for God choosing
them to be saved in Christ. That's
unconditional election.
Secondly,
the L and tulip limited atonement means
Christ came to die only for that group.
It's also called particular redemption,
definite atonement. Okay, that's the
second thing. Now guys, please listen to
these three because this passage
destroys all three blasphemous
doctrines. Jesse, I see your face. You
can go off camera now. All right. So the
I and tulip is irresistible grace.
Meaning the elect who have been chosen
by God will then have the Holy Spirit
make them alive,
enable them to believe, change their
heart. So when they hear the gospel,
they will run to Christ, believe in
Christ. So at that moment when the
spirit regenerates them, they won't be
able to resist the call to repentance
because the spirit will change them and
they will repent and be saved. Now watch
how Luke 19 41 and 44 destroys those
three
doctrines. Watch.
Irresistible grace. Meaning once the
spirit comes upon you and makes you
alive and Christ summons you or a gospel
preacher summons you, you will turn to
Christ because now your heart is changed
and you're filled with love for Christ.
So you won't turn away from him. Limit
atonement. Christ only came to die for
the elect. No one else. Unconditional
action. God chose the elect out of his
free will. Not because he saw that
someone would believe and therefore
knowing they'd believe. He chose them
for salvation. Okay, you understand
everyone guys? Everyone got it? Because
watch Luke 19:41-44 bury the three
doctrines of tulip in one passage which
I use in my debate against Turin Fan and
Matt Slick and they had no response.
They had none. Go watch the debates. I'm
not lying. Watch all three of these
doctrines destroyed. And these are the
passages the Holy Spirit kept hammering
me with. Convicting me with, right,
convicting me with,
right? Hammering me with
that's why I left Calvinism. And as he
approached Jerusalem and saw the city,
he cried over it, saying, "If you knew
in this day, even you, the things which
make for peace, but now they have been
hidden from your eyes." Number one,
Jesus is weeping bitterly. Jesus cannot
lie. He's not play acting. He's God in
the flesh.
He is heartbroken and crying. Why?
Because he says to Jerusalem, "You did
not know
my coming to you was for your peace. You
didn't recognize it." Number two, Christ
came to save all of Jerusalem, not just
the elect, because he came to bring them
peace. Well, that destroys limited
atonement
right there. But now they've been hidden
from your eyes. For the days will come
upon you, and your enemies will throw up
a barricade against you and surround you
and hem you in on every side, and they
will level you to the ground and your
children within you. Why? Why now will
you be destroyed and your children
within you? and they will leave will not
leave in you one stone upon another
because you did not recognize time of
your visitation. Now, I'm going to
explain what this means. Notice this
destroys irresistible grace because
Calvinists tell you that Christ only
came to die for the elect and gather the
elect. And the elect cannot resist him
and be destroyed because they'll be
changed and they'll run to him and be
preserved. But this group
would not turn to Christ to be saved,
leaving Christ no choice but to hand him
over to be destroyed. You just destroyed
right there irresistible grace. What
about unconditional election? Remember
it says God has chosen the elect not
because he saw they would believe but he
was free to choose whom he want. This
says that's a lie. Because God wanted to
save Jerusalem, but because they would
not believe, he then hands him over to
destruction. How can uncondition
election be true? Finally, notice he
says, "Why? You're going to be
destroyed? Because you didn't recognize
the time of your visitation. You didn't
recognize that I, God, came to visit you
for what? To bring all of you peace."
Now, let's see what this word visitation
means. All right. You ready?
Yeah,
>> I use this against Matt Slick and
Turtton fanfan and till this day not a
peep because they can't refute it. I'm
not lying. Go ask them. What does it
mean that Christ came visiting them? You
ready, brother?
I'm using Luke, right? They want solos
scriptor to scriptor. All right. Right.
>> Soloscriptor to scriptor. Right.
All right. I'm not using church
tradition.
He's weeping over them. He's crying.
He's heartbroken.
Is God play acting? Calvin is true. This
is all a lie. It's play acting. You
didn't recognize what would make for
your peace. So, he came to bring peace
to all of Jerusalem, not just the elect.
Yeah. But because they won't accept him,
he's now heartbroken because now he has
to hand them over. You didn't recognize
the time of your vitation. Here you go.
Let's see what it is. Luke 1:67-69.
and his father Zachchariah was filled
with the Holy Spirit. Don't you dare
tell me these are not words from the
Holy Spirit because the Holy Spirit now
filled Zechariah to prophesy. These are
the words of the spirit through
Zechariah. Now watch here.
And his father Zechariah was filled with
the Holy Spirit and prophesied saying,
"Blessed be the Lord God of Israel."
Why? For he visited. There's that word.
Why did he come to Jerusalem? You see
it?
>> The word visit, visitation.
>> Mhm.
>> And what does this visitation entail? He
visited and accomplished
redemption for his people
and raised up a horn of salvation for us
in the house of David, his servant. Oh,
wait. Let's continue.
So what did he come? Why did he visit
them? To bring their salvation,
redemption.
And what does that salvation entail?
What are they being saved from? Here you
go. Luke 1 1767. And you child will be
called the prophet of the most high. For
you will go on before the Lord to make
ready his ways to give his people
knowledge salvation by the forgiveness
of sins.
So why did Jesus visit them?
To bring them their salvation.
>> Salvation from what?
From their sins.
And yet could he save them?
He did accomplish it. Like obviously he
he did go through with it, but they just
did not accept it. So if he accomplished
redemption
and this redemption was the salvation of
all of Jerusalem, not just the elect.
How come they didn't get saved? How come
he didn't save them? This is what
Calvinists
>> are like the day of his visitation.
>> So now explain it to me. If Christ
accomplished salvation, he died to save
every creature. Why aren't every created
thing saved?
You're going Tony,
pray for Tony tomorrow. He's got a PET
scan. Let me know good news. We'll be
praying for you. So why are all
creatures saved
if you already accomplished it?
>> Because
because some creatures decided not to
accept that reconciliation.
>> That's the answer. This is where they
play games with you. Well, if Christ
died to accomplish salvation of
everyone, they must be saved. No,
because the Bible says though Christ
accomplished salvation.
Christ did
accomplish redemption. He paid the
price. That price was accepted so that
salvation is now a reality
accomplished by Christ. There's a
condition now for what Christ
actualized, what Christ accomplished,
you must believe in him to then receive
the benefits of what you've
accomplished. And this is what
we keep telling them and which they keep
ignoring.